ever played a game with crazy amounts of
stuff yet running so smoothly that it
seems like magic behind that buttery
smooth performance is more than just
powerful Hardware I started as a
graphics engineer almost 20 years ago
and since then I've always been
fascinated with optimizations but one
stands out as both incredibly simple yet
the reason why it works is more complex
than most people realize let's examine
one of the most effective optimization
techniques available and understand to
the same level of depth that experienced
Engineers do let's start with a little
world and we'll add a bunch of stuff to
it this will serve as our kind of test
beted to show things off so we'll keep
things reasonably simple let's go ahead
and add an object to the world here so
we've got our player and this object the
idea is relatively simple this object
will have several versions each being
progressively simpler so here's the most
complex or detailed version of the
object and we can sort of pan and the
camera down the line looking at these
simpler and simpler versions these will
be called levels of detail or LOD what
we're going to do is when we place one
of these objects in the world we'll
start at nearby for
convenience and the idea is as the
object gets further and further away
from the camera we cycle through the
different levels of detail for that
object so we're a bit further away we
switch to a lower level of detail a bit
further still and we can do that again
switch to an even lower level of detail
that sort of thing how many levels of
detail games use is a bit of tossup
since authoring them takes artist time
you may only have enough budget to build
a high and low level of detail or you
may have money to burn and you can build
a half dozen versions of the asset this
brings us to a really awesome
optimization that's used quite a bit
called imposters for many people this is
just another level of detail or a whole
other technique I mean it doesn't really
matter let's take these two objects here
in the distance from this Viewpoint what
are the differences between those two
not a whole lot but as we move forward
we can see that something is kind of off
with one of them this one looks
perfectly normal but the other one is
clearly just a picture that's rotating
with us this is a billboard or impostor
and from far enough away you really
can't tell the difference with a little
bit of work these imposters can be
really Advanced you can r out normal
Maps along with the diffuse you can
render them out from multiple viewpoints
and blend between them giving you a
highly versatile and Incredibly lowc
cost standing for the original asset
this scene here from my previous grass
video features something like 50,000
trees of various types and it's
trivially cheap to render due to most of
them being
imposters the question now is why does
this technique work so well the
intuitive answer is that these models
have fewer vertices and so then it sort
of makes sense that having fewer
vertices equals doing less work on the
GPU but press for more information than
that this is kind of where the
explanation stops for many people this
answer isn't wrong per se but at the
same time there's so much more going on
here if you were to go and buy a
state-of-the-art GPU they list their
performance these days in Tera flops
that's an absurd amount of computing
power so why just just reducing the
number of vertices in the scene make
such an outsize difference there's more
to the story back in the 9s gpus had
what was called a fixed function
pipeline which meant that the various
stages of the GPU were set in stone the
hardware had different units allocated
to different tasks what this meant
practically was that resources weren't
shared it was more like an assembly line
with things going in one end going
through a series of fixed steps and then
coming out fully processed on the other
end all this changed in around 2004 when
AMD or ATI at the time for those of us
who have been doing this for a long time
now developed the xenos GPU for the Xbox
360 this would be one of the earliest
designs that unified the Shader
architecture meaning that the Shader
processing units of the GPU were shared
between vertex and pixel shading duties
Nvidia followed not too long after I
think it was around 2006 with the Tesla
gener ation of gpus their first unified
Shader
architecture what this means is that the
GPU can now perform sort of load
balancing between the different types of
processing the GPU is free to
dynamically allocate resources between
say vertex and pixel processing leading
to more efficient GPU
utilization whereas before with the
fixed function pipeline it couldn't so
with that in mind my Uber powerful fancy
new GPU realistically shouldn't be
bothered too much by the introduction of
even a few million extra vertices
because doing one full screen pass would
be a few million pixels but wouldn't
even make a small dent in
performance if vertices and pixels are
basically shared now on the hardware
there shouldn't be a difference let's
look at this example I have this full
screen effect going meaning that I have
an expensive fragment Shader running on
the whole screen every single Pixel I
could be running anything this could be
changing the color doing various blurs
in reality there's so many things that
modern games do as post effects that the
exact contents of this Shader isn't that
important the only important Point here
is that we're running at 100 FPS now
let's work through some numbers together
to get a sense of the scale of the work
that GPU is currently doing so this
screen that I'm recording is on 1920 by
1080 so 1920 multiplied by 1080 is 2,730
,600 pixels in total or let's round that
to a cool 2 million pixels and I'm doing
a ton of work in the pixel Shader here
in the vertex Shader it's incredibly
bare there's barely any work in here in
fact the fragment or pixel Shader is
doing a magnitude of more work than this
but if I do something really dumb just
to illustrate a point and make a bot
load of triangles in fact one quad for
every pixel on the screen so there's 2
million pixels that means we've got
around 4 million triangles despite the
awesome power of this GPU the frame rate
drops catastrophically it absolutely
just grinds to a crawl so why is it that
the raw power of our GPU doesn't
translate to handling these 4 million
triangles effortlessly something else is
going on here let's unravel this further
if we're looking at a single quad that's
composed of two triangles which are
themselves composed of four vertices
it's not a whole lot if we we expand
that out to a full screen of quads we
get somewhere in the ballpark of 4
million triangles and thus roughly 4
million vertices in total if you think
about a screen having 2 million pixels
already and we're able to do many many
many full screen passes and all of the
associated Shader computation that comes
with it that number of vertices isn't
impressive we can try out a few
different numbers to see how this
affects things we already know that a
single quad is pretty quick but what
happen happens as we increase the number
of quads and thus the number of
triangles and vertices we can start out
by just doubling the number of quads
used and we don't see much in the way of
difference in performance if anything is
happening it's pretty minor at Best But
as we scale the count up progressively
as we make the size of the Quad smaller
and thus the number of quads needed to
fill up the screen increases effectively
increasing the triangle density on the
screen we start to notice a drop off in
performance initially it's nothing crazy
but what we see is that it's not a
gradual decline there's a real drop off
at some point between tiles roughly
sized 4x4 that's 4 pixels High and 4
pixels wide and then 2x two we see this
absolutely catastrophic drop off in
performance it's just bananas how bad
this gets let's talk a bit about how
gpus work to get a better understanding
of why this is failing so badly there's
this really great post by in videoa
called life of a triangle nvidia's
logical pipeline that kind of gives you
a behindth scenes look at what happens
between that API call and when things
finally appear on the screen AMD also
has a really great talk entitled all the
pipelines Journey Through the GPU which
has a nice overview of the different
stages that basically happen between you
attempting to draw something and pixels
appearing on the screen we'll Loosely
follow along with NV videas but I'll
provide you with a link to the AMD one
in the description
so if we imagine things starting out in
our own code we'll initiate the whole
thing with some sort of draw call in
webgl this might look something like gl.
draw elements Vulcan might be something
like BK command draw index Etc I mean
these specific commands aren't important
what happens now is that the driver goes
ahead and validates whatever you sent
making sure the data even makes sense
before prepping it into a GPU friendly
format that makes its way over to the
GPU which does some processing let's
just kind of skim this the important
takeaway here is that it creates batches
of triangles to work on and these are
sent to these parts of the GPU that
Nvidia calls gpcs or Graphics processing
clusters let's not wander too far off
into the weeds here but let's just
mentally go with the idea of gpcs as
being capable of handling a portion of
the graphics rendering independently
from others so obviously then the more
you have of these the better because
that means your GPU can theoretically do
more work simultaneously the important
part at this stage is that these will
grab the vertex data for the triangles
and begin scheduling work for each
vertex it'll do the vertex processing at
this point and the Nvidia doc goes over
various tricks and optimizations they
use which aren't super important for the
sake of Simplicity in the AMD talk they
specifically refer to this as the
Primitive assembler or PA stage whose
job is to put together a triangle and
then forward that onto the rasterization
stage this is a bit like a step in an
assembly line that takes a bunch of
pieces the individual vertices and
builds your Primitives for you usually
triangles the next stage basically
involves figuring out who's going to be
doing the fragment Shader work so at a
course level they're kind of testing the
triangle against quads on the screen and
divvying up the work you can see on
nvidias depending on the screen
rectangles they're handing off the work
to different gpcs and AMD has a a
similar note about doing some scan
conversion to test triangle overlap the
end result is a bunch of fragment or
pixel Shader work is getting queed up so
what it does here is gets these 2x two
quads of pixels that's four pixels per
quad and cues those up together you can
see both Nvidia and AMD both referen
this and the simple reason is that at
that size they can do some efficient
calculations stuff like texture
gradients for M mapping well a 2X two
quad has just enough information to do
that while not being more complex to
implement from a hardware point of view
so pretty much everyone will do this at
this point there's a bit more work to do
depth testing blending various other
operations before finally getting output
but that's how pixels are born one
obvious question that falls out of this
is if 2x two quads of pixels are the
smallest possible unit the GPU works
with what happens if I draw a triangle
smaller than that good question and this
is where where you're realizing that
gpus are basically built with you could
say that it's an assumption about what
you're going to draw and that's pretty
reasonable Hardware Engineers are
looking for ways to maximize the gpu's
potential and then teach you what to do
and what not to do so basically there's
an assumption that there's a given ratio
between triangle size and pixels covered
and at some point past this they'll
still support whatever it is you're
trying to do but in a very disapproving
way when you try to draw something
smaller the GPU absolutely can still do
it well what happens is that you've got
this 2x2 quad which is kind of like the
smallest unit the GPU works with the
triangle inhabits this quad here what
happens to the other three the answer is
that the GPU still does the work but
then it just throws away the result in
fact it's always doing this just most of
the time you don't notice it in this
case it threw away 75% of the work but
let's imagine that we have a bigger
triangle so let's look at a bigger
screen here and then we've got a
triangle that's being rendered so it's
touching a bunch of pixels right except
we now know that the GPU works with
quads so it's actually touching a whole
bunch of quads some of which lie right
on the edges of the triangle all of
these quads here that lie on the edge of
the triangle they have pixels that lie
within the triangle and some that don't
but the GPU will perform the work for
the entire quad each time there's not
much you can do about this this it's a
natural consequence of rendering some of
this work the GPU is just going to have
to throw away it'll be wasted but what
you can affect is what kind of triangles
you feed to the GPU really small
triangles are an obvious terrible case
you get really poor quad utilization
throwing away an obscene amount of GPU
performance but we can go a bit further
and examine different topologies for a
mesh by topology I mean the way the
vertices are arranged to form the mesh
you can triangulate a mesh in many ways
and it's important to understand that
they're not all treated the same by the
GPU a person a senior Graphics engineer
at Epic Games known extremely well
within graphic circles as humus has a
great blog which I've referenced in the
past for example in the last video I
talked about occlusion systems and one
point I made was based on a talk he did
for Avalanche games anyway there's a
nice article talking about how the
topology of a mesh affects the
performance what the article goes into
detail is examining how different
triangulations of the same mesh result
in different performance while things
like the mesh's area or other things
like number of triangles are kept
constant the findings shouldn't surprise
us as we can see what the test did was
to increase the number of vertices and
gauge performance we can see that the
max area approach worked out best while
making ever thinner triangles did poorly
and you already know why because you end
up with po quad utilization and thus the
GPU does a lot of work that it has to
throw away as ail's research showed the
specific way that a mesh is triangulated
has a very direct impact on performance
and better triangulation can lead to
better quad utilization and thus less
wasted work from the GPU so given that
understanding what happens now if
instead of one quad per pixel what
happens if we push things further let's
start upping the number and will go to
four quads per pixel or nine quads per
pixel or even 16 quads per pixel or
whatever and what you'll see is that the
frame rate will start to tank further
and further it's a lot of triangles but
not that many it's about 2 million to
start and grows to 8 million 18 32
million this was an interesting topic of
exploration on G tr's blog who was
looking at the effect of sub pixel
triangles on performance as they noted
near the bottom as you crank the number
of vertices up the frame rate absolutely
tanks even if you're rendering to lower
resolution this post is quite old now
and I don't have access to the exact
same setup that was used there so my
numbers don't match exactly but I am
seeing terrible performance which is
realistically all that matters this goes
back to the idea that your GPU is this
super powerful monster that can take on
anything and a bunch of triangles in the
grand scheme of things isn't that much
so then what's behind this and
performance let's revisit that primitive
assembly stage but this time through the
lens of amd's R DNA architecture as
detailed by their Journey Through the
GPU talk we touched on that earlier
where we can think of primitive assembly
like a step in an assembly line that
takes a bunch of pieces the individual
vertices and builds your perimeters for
you usually triangles so on slide 19 on
the r DNA architecture we can see that
various parts of the pipeline have been
labeled
and there's this one here called the
Primitive assembler which as we know is
important for assembling vertices into a
triangle and then it outputs it to the
next stage which is often called
rasterization this is where it gets
interesting so this will obviously vary
from architecture to architecture I mean
you can go and find the information
sometimes for example we can look at the
r DNA architecture white paper from AMD
this goes into some details on how the
navi class gpus work there's a lot of
info in here but we can kind of focus on
what we want from here which is some
info about primitive assembly
specifically they talk about how they
scale the architecture so as we can see
they have this detailed breakdown of how
the navi class gpus like the radon
rx5700 XT which came out in 2019 we can
see how they're structured they consist
of what are called Shader engines the
radon RX 5700 XD has two of these and
within a Shader engine they're further
divided into Shader arrays which contain
among other things A Primitive unit and
a rasterizer this is analogous to the
Nvidia setup we saw earlier where they
partition their gpus into what we called
gpcs or Graphics processing clusters so
the neat thing is then you can connect
that to this section later in the white
paper where they talk about how the
Primitive units assemble triangles let's
just read this directly the Primitive
units assemble triangles from vertices
and are Al responsible for fixed
function tessellation each primitive
unit has been enhanced and supports
culling up to two Primitives per clock
twice as fast as the prior generation
one primitive per clock is output to the
rasterizer so each primitive unit can
output one primitive per clock so while
the GPU may be exceedingly powerful in
some respects for example pixel
processing it's still Bound by the rate
the Primitive assembler can pass things
off to the rasterization stage so that's
neat because it lets you know more
specifically what the upper limit is for
a given architecture on how fast these
things can just feed triangles to the
rasterization stage this is going to
vary wildly from GPU to GPU architecture
to architecture maybe a good idea if
you're working on a console and have
some hard numbers to work against but
personally I think it's just best to get
the broad Strokes idea by throwing more
and more vertices even if they're not
visible you're forcing them through
primitive assembly which may kind of
bottleneck things depending on the card
you're using slightly older cards
especially couldn't output them many
Primitives per clock and so you'll end
up starving later stages since this is a
bit like an assembly line as G TR points
out on their blog let's say that you're
dumping out a zillion small triangles
you're not making the most of the
rasterization stage that follows it in
fact a ton of performance is getting
flushed down the toilet so now we have
all the tools and Foundation to go back
to this simple optimization that we
introduced at the beginning but
understanding at a much deeper level
what's actually happening whatever your
preconceptions of why level of detail
worked now you understand that the GPU
really isn't all that good at rendering
a bunch of microt triangles and spends a
disproportionate amount of computing
power doing it computing power that
could have been used to make other stuff
look more awesome we also Now understand
that we are also inundating the GPU with
useless small triangles which beyond all
that 2x two quad stuff you're forcing
this to go through primitive assembly a
few years ago unreal unveiled nanite a
really interesting new technology that
I'm sure you've heard of by now but if
you haven't no worries unreal's nanite
is in essence a continuous and automatic
level of detail system no need for
artists to do this unreal handles it
automatically we can look at their
sigraph 2021 presentation entitled
nanite a deep dive and one interesting
thing that pops up is they confirm a lot
of what we've talked about here on this
page about 80 pages in this is a very
long presentation they talk about some
technical decisions they made we can see
here that they mention just how crappy
tiny triangles are and they point out
the gpus are built with parallel pixels
in mind but not triangles which jives
with what we've seen I mean they're the
Epic team they've done their homework
as they mentioned in their slides a lot
of modern gpus can set up four triangles
per clock Max so so A Primitive assembly
bottleneck is a very real problem that
they set out to solve or at least work
around so what they did was to write a
software rasterizer for micr triangles
and that ended up being considerably
faster we don't have to understand the
details of their implementation but now
at least we understand their motivation
if you think you'd like to learn more
about game Deb from experienced Graphics
engineer I have a variety of courses
available very suitable for beginners so
if you find yourself wanting to get a
bit better at gamedev and delve a little
deeper on some subjects check them out
otherwise if you'd still like to support
me and help choose what topic I cover
next you can vote on my patreon page
cheers